[Laughter]
i'd like to welcome you uh here to
jerusalem i'm delighted to see you
president of the european commission
uh olsala
founder leyn
it's a pleasure to host you and your
distinguished delegation here in israel
and
we know that you're a great friend of
the jewish people and a great friend of
israel so we really like you
uh being the first female president of
the european commission in history i'm
glad you met a bunch of members from my
government which
i'm proud to say is the
government with the most amount of
female ministers in israel's history
it's also the
uh
the government with the greatest variety
in in our history we have uh
religious and secular right and left
jews and arabs and it's uh quite a
juggling act but
we're keeping it up
yesterday my government
celebrated a year in office
and what a year it's been
over the last year we rejuvenated
israel's ties with our neighbors in the
region we want to build bridges to peace
we repositioned climate change on
israel's agenda and made it a national
priority
and we redefined israel place in the
global community
and i'm happy to say that today israel
and europe are in a very strong and
positive trajectory
trade innovation economic cooperation
are soaring
we're witnessing our partnership
reach new heights
half a year ago israel joined horizon
europe and again this week my government
approved that israel will be joining
creative europe
and today will be joining hands towards
even greater endeavors
the jewish people in europe share a long
history
today we can look forward knowing that
europe is in the hands of leaders such
as yourself
who understand the weight and the the
responsibility and take firm action
in the face of anti-semitism
your words today at the the ben gurion
university were
were powerful you said israel in europe
are bound to be friends and allies
because the history of europe
is the history of the jewish people
i could not agree more
so i'd like to take this opportunity to
congratulate you madame president on
your honorary doctorate from ben gurion
university of the negev
it's a good university madame doctor
with the ongoing and devastating war in
ukraine
comes vast global implications and it's
a time for the international community
to work together
we
even in our region we're seeing a
potential for great famine
and
distress that can
can have the
profound implications for the stability
and and the
welfare of people
which is why today um both of us will be
discussing ways where the eu and
israel can cooperate on food security
energy and more
in recent years israel went from being a
gas importer to becoming a gas exporter
and we're currently working to produce
natural gas from more natural gas from
israel's economic waters
i'd like to take this opportunity to
commend the respective leaders of the eu
for their recent decision
to censure iran
at the international atomic energy
agency
this decision came after iran refused to
give the iaea
satisfactory explanations for traces of
uranium found in sites that iran iran
failed to declare
and if hiding information wasn't enough
the iranian regime also threatened to
retaliate
if the iaea were to vote against them
and when the iaea indeed voted against
iran iran responded by turning off 27
surveillance cameras from nuclear sites
across the country
essentially cutting off the
international community's ability
to see what iran's doing
this is a very dangerous move
iran's belligerent actions should be a
wake-up call for the international
community
and should be met with clear and strong
consequences
increased pressure and holding iran
accountable
at the u.n security council
the only way for iran to be stopped
is if we act and stop them
israel and eu are natural partners and
we we've got a lot to talk about
at dinner today but before we roll up
our sleeves and get to work
i really again want to thank you for
your deep friendship to the jewish
people and the state of israel
we know that it's uh
from your heart
and thank you for being a partner in
this new chapter of relations between
israel and europe thank you very much
and welcome to israel thank you thank
you very much prime minister thank you
for the warm welcome
i receive here in jerusalem and indeed
the european union and israel share
ties and bonds unique bonds because we
have a shared history and we share
values
and therefore i'm very glad about the
you mentioned an excellent cooperation
we have in the different fields like
energy culture you mentioned the trade
of course
research and innovation outstanding or
health just to name a few
and on health i want to thank you and
the people of israel
and the scientists of israel too because
you have been outstanding at the
beginning of the pandemic when all of us
were looking for a effective and safe
vaccine and the fact that you had an
outstanding approach to the vaccine
campaign here in israel
with collecting data on a broad
scientific basis sharing the data with
us gave you a front runner a position
where you proved to the world that the
mrna vaccines are safe and effective and
i cannot thank you enough for that
because
we know by experience now how
devastating this pandemic was and how
important the development and then the
application of the mrna vaccines has
been
i'm very happy indeed that israel is
participating in our research and
innovation program horizon europe that's
wonderful because you are outstanding
and indeed your scientists are
phenomenal and i'm convinced that both
israel and the european union will
benefit tremendously from this
cooperation
i had
a first impression of the ben gurion
university today i will tell you at
dinner it was fascinating you know how
excellent they are but i'm still
thrilled
about all the stories and the research
passion that i could sense there in ben
gurion university mainly also of course
for the pressing issues that we have to
tackle together so
i think this great cooperation will make
our partnership even stronger
this part is particularly important in
these difficult and bleak times you
mentioned russia's war against ukraine
and it has indeed severe consequences
for europe and far beyond and we need to
work together to address them
the first is indeed that we want to
boost our energy cooperation with israel
the european union was the biggest most
important
client from the supplier russia
oil gas and coal
but with the beginning of this war and
the attempt of russia to blackmail us
through energy by
deliberately cutting the energy supplies
we decided to cut off and to get rid of
the dependency of russian fossil fuels
and
to move away from russia and diversify
to trustworthy
suppliers so
it is for us very important and i'm very
grateful that we are now discussing this
fascinating project that you are willing
to increase the deliveries of gas
to the european union via egypt
and tomorrow we will already take a very
important step with the signing of a
trilateral
memorandum of understanding between
israel the european union and egypt
this will help step up the deliveries of
energy to europe so here you will bring
from israel via pipeline hopefully one
day hydrogen ready pipeline to egypt it
will be liquefied to lng and then
brought to the european union
i think this is a very important project
but we know that over time we should
jointly explore the use of
infrastructure for renewable energy this
is the energy of the future it's good
for
climate it's good for our independence
it creates high highly paying jobs
so it is an outstanding step bringing
our energy cooperation to the next level
you have here in abundance all the
resources that are necessary for
renewables i mean sun and wind and other
resources
therefore i'm very much looking forward
to intensify the cooperation on that
field
second we have the duty to help to
protect the world from the a major food
crisis you were mentioning it
the kremlin's war and russia's blockade
of the black sea
are threatening the global food security
especially in vulnerable regions like
yours here
20 million ton of grain are trapped in
ukraine and cannot be exported so we're
doing our part and our best to help to
export it
to get the grain out of ukraine to boost
our own production to support neighbors
in ramping up food production as well
but we have to look further to the mid
and long term and here israel can play a
tremendously important important role
role
because you have a unique expertise in
innovative
resource efficient agriculture
i mean i don't have to tell you that the
founders of your country country have
made basically crops spring up from the
driest of deserts you made the desert
bloom
and today the world desperately needs
these technologies to really have a
shift what food supply and food
dependency is concerned
finally
the eu and israel have both in common
the interest in a secure and stable
middle east
and we see you as a crucial partner in
pursuing this objective i want to
commend you
on the normalization of your relations
with some of your arab neighbors the
abraham accord this is a big step
forward
and in time
it could i hope also help advance
relations between israel and palestine
the palestinians
we strongly condemn
the recent terror attacks in israel and
we mourn their victims
the violence must stop so we very much
welcome all the efforts towards peace
and we think that the abraham accords
could offer
hope towards that goal i'm very much
looking forward to the dinner
there are many more topics we have to
discuss and many thanks for having me
thank you very much